paris sa plage ses palmiers ses transats
sait désormais ce qui est proposé aux
parisiens sur les quais de la seine
jusqu'au 18 août l'opération lancée par
la mairie de paris
paris plage s'étend sur trois kilomètres
autour de l'île de la cité de notre dame
ambiance riviera donc mais baignade
interdite et c'est pauline rêve naze qui
est à la plage scène ordinaire d'une
plage en été
les pâtes et les transats la crème
solaire et les bateaux mouches
car nous sommes bien à paris entre l'île
de la cité et les tuileries trois
kilomètres de littoral à ménager pendant
tout l'été de musique
il bat plupart en pleurs et l'impatience
et y meurent
150 parasols et 300 transat pour se
détendre comme on peut cette fois il y
aurait eu un tout petit peu plus de
place encore mieux je m'attendais à un
petit peu mieux que ça mais sympa quand
même super bien et son banc et puis fait
de très beau une station balnéaire en
plein coeur de paris on s'y croirait et
on se prendrait presque à rêver en
regardant le ciel
mais pour y croire vraiment mieux vaut
fermer les yeux et oublier la foule là
des petits on n'a pas de place on peut
pas bronzer on a pris des couleurs
ailleurs on aimerait bien continuer mais
ça marche mais c'est très bien c'est
génial sans pollution
sans pollution en bas peut-être mais
d'en haut sur les quais la fermeture des
berges risque de provoquer l'engorgement
car chaque jour 200 mille véhicules
empruntent ces voies pour les opposants
à paris-plage menée par le président de
l'automobile club
la politique de la mairie c'est du sable
aux yeux